आई एक्सटेंड माय हार्टफुल ग्रेटिंग्स टू
ऑल ऑफ यू टुगेदर हिअर टू सेलिब्रेट द
जयंती ऑफ आदि जगतगुरु श्री शिवरात्रि सर
शिव योगी
महास्वामी जी फील डीपली प्लेस टू
पार्टिसिपेट इन दिस हिस्टोरिक ओके दैट्स द
ग्रेट सेट हिस लाइफ विजन एंड टीचिंग
स्पंटिन्यू टू इंस्पायर एंड गाइड काउंसलेस
पीपल आफ्टर मोर देन थाउजेंड
एक एजेस सफल
ह्यूमैनिटी थ्रू देर एंड कंपशन दे लाइफ
रिमाइंड अस ट्रू ग्रेटनेस लाइट इन अथॉरिटी
और वेल बट इन सैक्रिफाइस सर्विस एंड
स्पिरिचुअल
ग्रेटेस्ट आदि जगत गुरु श्री शिवर रात्री
शिव शिवजोगी महास्वामी जी साइंस एज ए बिकन
ऑफ लाइफ एंड इंस्परेशन
इन द 10थ सेंचुरी जगतगुरु एस्टब्लिश द
जगतगुरु श्री
वीर सिंहासन महासस्थान मोतुर
व्हाट बिगेन सैक्रेट स्पिरिचुअल सेंटर सून
बिकम अ पावरफुल फोर्स फॉर सोशियल
ट्रांसपोर्टेशन
द मोस्ट
सेंटर विडम लंगिंग जनरेशन विल ऑफ
डिसिप्लिन डिवशन एंड कंपशन
अनबोकन गुरु लीनेज ऑफ सुर लिविंग सोल ऑफ
दिस ग्रेट ट्रेडिशन इट है
स्पिरिचुअल पास डाउन जनरेशन
आदि जगतगुरु महास्वामी जी
इन स्पिरिचुअल डिसिप्लिन एंड डीप इन आवर
विस्टम
जगतगुरु डॉक्टर श्री शिवरात्रि राजेंद्र
महास्वामी जी कैरिड लिगसी फॉरवर्ड विजनरी
एंड कंपशन पब्लिक सर्विस आई हैव बीन टोल्ड
दैट हिज कंट्रीब्यूशन टू रिलीजन एजुकेशन
हेल्थ केयर एंड कल्चर आर बेनिफिटिंग
मिलियंस
लेडीज एंड जेंटलमैन कर्नाटक इज द सेक्रेट
लैंड ऑफ द ग्रेट सेंस
बस सर हुज टीचिंग कंटिन्यू टू इंस्पायर
ह्यूमैनिटी अक्रॉस जनरेशन
प्रोफाउंड मैसेज का बेलाश
इज नॉट मेयरली एक्सप्रेशन बट वे ऑफ लाइफ
आई एम हैप्पी टू नो दिस फिलोसफी फाइंड
ट्रू रिफ्लेक्शन इन द आइडियल एंड
एक्टिविटीज ऑफ द मठ
वेयर स्पिरिचुअल पर्स्यूट एंड सोशल सर्विस
गोड इन हैंड
आई एम प्लीज टू नोट दैट अंडर द गाइडेंस
एंड पैट्रोनेज ऑफ द मोस
एस महाविद्या पीठ हैज़ एमआई एस वन ऑफ़ द
इंडियास डिस्टिंग्विश इंस्टीटश डेडिकेटेड
टू द एडवांसमेंट ऑफ एजुकेशन एंड सोशल
डेवलपमेंट
विथ सेवरल इंस्टीट्यूशन अक्रॉस द वर्ल्ड
इट इज एंगेज इन शेपिंग यंग माइंड्सिंग
हेल्थ केयर एमवरिंग
अपलिफ्टिंग रूरल कम्युनिटी
प्रिजर्विंग कल्चर एंड स्ट्रेंथिंग द
फाउंडेशन ओपन इंक्लूसिव सोसाइटी सुतुर मठ
स्टार्ट टू एस वन ऑफ द पिलर ऑफ सोशल
डेवलपमेंट
लेडीज एंड जेंटलमैन
इन एन एज ऑफ ग्राफिक चेंज
एंड अनसर्टेनिटी स्पिरिचुअल गाइडेंस
एसेंशियल फॉर नर्चरिंग सोशल हार्मोनी
एथिकल लीडरशिप यूथ एंपावरमेंट एंड इनर
रेिलियंस
एस वी मूव टू अस विज़ ऑफ डेवलप इंडिया बाय
2047 वी नीड बोथ द पावर ऑफ टेक्नोलॉजी एंड
द स्ट्रेंथ ऑफ वैल्यूस
डेवलप इंडिया रिक्वेस्ट द इंटीग्रेशन ऑफ
मॉडर्न एजुकेशन वि मोरल विसडम इनोवेशन वि
एनवायरमेंटल रिस्पांसिबिलिटी इकोनमिक
ग्रोथ विद सोशल इंक्लूजन एंड प्रोग्रेस वि
कंपैशन
द गवर्नमेंट ऑफ इंडिया इज वर्किंग वि दिस
होलिस्टिक विजन इंस्टीट्यूशन लाइक कैन
प्ले सब्सटेंसियल रोल इन दिस नेशनल इंडिया
आवर स्पिरिचुअल इंस्टीट्यूशन रिमाइंड अस
ऑफ द वैल्यूस दैट फाइंड ह्यूमैनिटी टूगेदर
द वैल्यूस ऑफ कंपैशन टोलरेंस म्यूचुअल
रेस्पेक्ट एंड एंड कलेक्टिव
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
दीज़ आर नॉट मेयरली आइडियल्स ऑफ द पास्ट दे
आर एसेंशियल फाउंडेशंस फॉर स्ट्रांग एंड
हारमोनियस मॉडर्न वर्ल्ड द गवर्नमेंट ऑफ
इंडिया रिमेंस कमिटेड टू बाइंडिंग
बिल्डिंग
फ्यूचर गाइडेड बाय इंक्लूजन सर्विस एंड
ह्यूमन डिग्निटी
आवर ग्रेटेस्ट लाइ इन आवर यूथ दे एनर्जी
क्रिएटिविटी वैल्यूज एंड कैरेक्टर
द डेस्टिनी ऑफ़ इंडिया विल बी सेव्ड नॉट
ओनली बाय देयर स्किल्स एंड नॉलेज बट बाय
देयर इंटीग्रिटी एंड सेंस ऑफ पर्पस। आई
आस्क इंस्टीट्यूशन लाइक शॉर्ट मौत टू
कंटिन्यू इंस्पायरिंग यंग माइंड्स
नार्चरिंग रिस्पांसिबल सिटीजंस एंड
गाइडिंग द आर्टिफेक्ट ऑफ टुमारोस इंडिया।
द सेलिब्रेशन ऑफ द जयंती ऑफ आदि जगत गुरु
श्री
शिवरात्रि शिव योगी महास्वामी जी इज
रीमेशन ऑफ कलेक्टिव कमिटमेंट टू लाइफ
गाइडेड बाय धर्म कंपशन सर्विस एंड यूनिट
आई प्रेज द डिवाइन ग्रेस ऑफ शिव जोगी
मास्वामी जी कंटिन्यूस टू इंस्पायर दिस टू
अप
डिसीजन एंड टू कंट्रीब्यूट इन आवर नेशनल
एफर्ट्स फॉर पीस प्रोस्पेरिटी एंड
स्पिरिचुअल स्ट्रेंथ। थैंक यू जय हिंद जय
भारत।